Well, church, what a beautiful day.
Beautiful morning this week
is actually kids camp.
And so if you would in, in your mind this week, think
of praying for that.
There's prayer bracelets out in the
lobby to remind you of that.
But our heart, our hope is that God would change lives
by his love forever.
Just like Hensley's sitting here in front of you
to do the same thing, to declare that faith, to allow her
salvation to be declared to you.
We pray for more of that this week,
but over the last few months, she's been talking
to her parents about what it means to be a Christian.
And so she wants today to declare that through her baptism,
that Jesus is her Lord and Savior.
Is that right? Amen. All right.
Based on your profession of faith, I get to baptize you.
In the name of the Father, son, and Holy Spirit,
Amen.
Lemme pray. Lemme pray for you. Lord, I thank you.
I thank you for this life that gives evidence to you
and that you want to use for the rest of her days
to pursue you and live for you.
We pray for more, pray that children, students, adults,
would see the need to be humbled before you
and follow you as their Lord and Savior.
Uh, we pray, God, you'd use this week to do that in each
of us you would use today
to propel us forward towards humility in you for your glory.
In Jesus' name, amen. Amen. Love you church. We are sent.